it turns out that I've been passionate
about building design tools since I was
a graduate student in fact that was my
dissertation topic right build
interactive sketching tool that would
take what you could draw on paper and
turn it into a functional prototype and
so I'm really happy to reengage that
area of work and so today I'm going to
talk about some recent contributions
I've made in the area of design thinking
tools so let me just start by giving
some background and motivation for my
work so a large part of my research
addresses problems and opportunities
that are triggered by the adoption of
software tools for the conceptual phases
of design so domains of interest for me
are in interaction design graphic design
other forms of visual communication
design and more recently been thinking
about technical writing and programming
work from a creative perspective when
it's a conceptual phase what I mean is
that anything that precedes
implementation so it could be example
finding that could be idea generation it
could be selection and refinement the
use of software tools for the conceptual
phases of design is problematic there's
a lot of friction and the reason why is
that for 40 years we have designed tools
from the perspective of productivity
whereas for design which is a canonical
form of a creative task we need to think
about how we design them from the
perspective of creativity and that gap
between productivity and creativity is
really important to close there are many
compelling reasons but let me give you
the one that I think is convincing at
least to me this comes from Richard
Florida's book that he boldly calls the
rise of the creative class you may have
read this one but in that book he
reports that about one third of the
national workforce is engaged in design
and other forms of creative work and
that further enabling that creative
class is vital to our economic and
social prosperity one way to do that is
to and extend and enhance tools that
that creative class has available to
work with and so I try to do this by
bridging three themes one is what I call
making and that tries to combine
computer science with HCI and reflects
my interest in building tools from an
understanding of human behavior
the second is creativity and this refers
both to the theory and the practice of
design and other forms of creative work
and theories of reflection brainstorming
and in particular creative cognition
have had a large influence on what I do
and it's really interesting that the
past five to ten years the Chi community
has really engaged that literature and
the last one is crowds and this refers
to both online communities and crowd
computing and I got interested this
actually for my sabbatical in 2008 when
I went to Microsoft Research and I had a
really amazing opportunity to study one
of their innovation communities inside
the organization and it's like wow this
is really amazing and I wanted to make
that more of a main part of my research
so what sabbatical sabbaticals are for
so I mapped around the perimeter my
recent publications and work that I've
done and I try to push my work at the
intersection of those themes because I
think that's where we can make the most
interesting contributions and so today
I'll talk about the for around the top
and the one thing I want to say when I
go through the talk I'm simply going to
describe the people that use our tools
as users and not necessarily try to
tease apart if as an expert or a novice
or a non designer doing design work I've
just say user if it matters I'll try to
make the distinction so let's get
started on the first one the first
project I want to describe involves
helping users work more effectively with
multiple ideas during the conceptual
phases of design when you tackle almost
any creative task what is the first
instruction that you get generate as
many ideas as you can we've known that
for a really long time so for example
here I design a responded with multiple
sketches in response to a given design
problem and say product design the
theoretical basis for that goes back
really far goes back to Osborne's work
on applied imagination where he argued
that the best ideas come at the tail end
of idea generation so if you want to get
to the really good ideas then you have
to generate many ideas the problem is
that this behavior is not well supported
in existing design tools or the practice
of using those tools so for instance on
the
this is kind of the dominant model in
digital drawing tools where they Susumu
going to work with a document model and
you just map your alternatives to
different file names that are aptly
named you know concept one concept to
concept three and so forth and in
research the way that we think about
working with multiple ideas for example
could be done through a tabbed interface
and so this is an example from the
juxtapose system that Bjorn Hartmann has
got clemmer dead here the problem though
is that other researchers argue is that
these types of representations hinder
interpretation and the projection of
meaning what the heck does that mean
right let me give you an example so take
either those two representations which
is the leading alternative which one is
favored which one was tried but no
longer in contention and which ones are
in-between we can't even see all the
ideas anymore I mean it's small but it's
an important part of the creative
process and so what I wanted to do is
try to bring that back as best as I
could and so my approach was to explore
a new model I called interactive spatial
maps and the concept was implemented as
part of a prototype sketching
application and the larger window is
just a very crude approximation of what
you would get in the digital drawing
tool and our spatial maps is in the
lower right and it runs as a floating
window can be on your primary display or
if you want to you can move it to a
secondary display if you have one and
the key idea of the spatial maps is that
we allow you to directly manipulate the
representations on a zoomable workspace
and so you can project meaning by using
the dimensions of both space and scale
so for example the user here has a
number of alternatives and the one that
they think is favored at the moment they
can scale it make it larger and position
it near the center and the one that's
maybe they tried but didn't necessarily
like they can scale it down and position
it away and the others are somewhat in
between so when you look at the
workspace relative to what I showed
before you should get an immediate
intuitive sense as to how they're
thinking about the design situation and
you can see all the ideas at once so let
me just show you a little video clip of
this in action
ener is working on a tablet PC running
the team storm client software the
client interface allows the designer to
freely sketch on multiple canvases for
rapid externalization of creative ideas
standard editing features such as
zooming and editing control are
supported every new idea is drawn within
a new canvas and we allow users to have
as many canvases as they want ideas are
managed through a resizable zoomable
floating workspace window that allows
for spatial arrangement and resizing of
canvases as they come in and out of
favor selecting a canvas in the
workspace makes it the focus of the
editing region a colored viewfinder
appears on the canvas in the workspace
to show the scope of the users editing
this color corresponds to the color of
the border around the main sketching
window okay so to give you a sense of
how it works and we did an evaluation
and I wanted to compare it to how it
works with relative to a tabbed
interface as represented say in
Microsoft OneNote and a layered canvas
that's represented in Photoshop so just
briefly our procedure with it was a
within subjects design we had 18 users
all trained in some form of visual
design and they used all three tools so
every person used one of the three tools
with one Taos next tool different tasks
and so forth and we had a number of
different measures we measured process
outcomes so the number of ideas and more
categories ideas the switches between
the ideas we measured strategies that
they use for how they worked with the
ideas during the task we measured their
preferences and we got qualitative
feedback and we had a lot of interesting
findings and if you're want to read
about all of them you can look at our GI
2010 paper it's one of my all-time
favorite papers and let me just give you
the highlights so one of the highlights
was that users actively organize and
reflect during the idea generation tasks
it was a core part of generating ideas
and so the idea sets weren't passive
they weren't an archive people actively
engaged them throughout the task to help
them come up with more ideas I thought
that was really interesting when they
used our tool for example they had about
ten reflections where they look at the
entire idea set at once and twelve
organizational interactions where they
had map either the idea either unto
space or scale and that was more than
what they would do with the other two
tools and my interpretation was that is
that there's a need to engage those idea
sets and when you give people the
opportunity to do it they'll take
advantage of it but they also wanted
more and so a couple of the ideas that
we got through the qualitative feedback
was that they wanted more ways to engage
that idea set and so we went back and
extended the tool to offer a grid-based
view if you look at all the ideas at the
same scale and a time-based view so you
can look at the evolution of your ideas
over time and you could do color coded
tags that you would attach the idea you
could toggle their visibility okay so
they wanted different ways to look at
that set of ideas because we allowed
them to directly manipulate and organize
and reflect on the ideas there's a very
strong preference for spatial maps and
maybe the biggest outcome of the study
was that we showed that spatial maps is
a viable approach and an effective
approach for working with ideas and so I
would love to see this be extended and
implemented in the growing class of
digital drawing tools are now available
through app stores as well as just on
the web but I also think there's a lot
of opportunity to really dig deeper and
how people do exploratory work and say
areas of technical writing and
programming and I know this has been
around for a really long time but
there's a lot more that we can do in the
space and I hope to engage some of that
work in the future but one of the things
that really piqued my interest during
this project was this notion of
reflection about how people look back to
engage with things that they've done and
try to extract meaning from it and that
led me to Don Joan's work he has a
number of theories of reflection and
reflection is a theory of practice and
he developed that theory of practice
through observations of how
architectural designers work and
practice he talks about many different
granularities of reflection but the one
that I liked the most was reflection on
action it's intentional critical
thinking about prior work to learn from
your experience and to project that into
the future so if you ever look back at
say a talk or a tie paper to think about
what you might do next
you've engaged in reflection on action
okay now I'm just gonna call that
reflection for this talk and I do it all
the time actually did for this talk I
did for the last paper and so forth
reflection typically benefits from
having a representation of design
process and designers often construct
their own representations through
different organizational and naming
strategies so this is just an example of
one that we uncovered from a study that
we did so in this case the use numbers
to indicate project priority they use
letters to indicate status they have
highlights indicate unmet dependencies
and they organize iterations using
folder structures it's not that the
naming schemes are bad it's just that
the hierarchal representation doesn't
reveal the relationships in a way that's
meaningful to the user so what did they
learn from that project what was a proud
moment what was a critical incident and
I'm arguing is that you can't really
know because it doesn't come out of the
visualization or the representation is
it short you see this explicit because
what really kind of I love Shone's
theory but what sort of kind of bothered
me about it is it seemed very tacit and
very implicit and I wanted to think
about what if we could actually have
them make that explicit in a
visualization so people can engage this
in a more kind of direct way have you
seen other buildings before you really
looked in people do have a regular on a
number of interviews and studies that we
did and found that people actually do
engage in fact his whole book is
dedicated to trying to communicate that
people do this and it's a very important
part of how people work in the design
profession yeah okay and I would argue
that representation design process that
have built and research also don't
necessarily answer those questions and
so one very nice tool was done by
Mendel's and others in car 2011 called
freed it was a very nice visualization
that you can construct by hand and once
you had the visualization you could
engage in reflection the problem is the
cost of construction we're
against the utility of the visualization
and others visualizations for
state-based design histories and
exploratory behavior
very nice contributions but they didn't
really target reflective behavior and
that's what I wanted to do and so we
created a tool called reflection space
and the key innovation of reflection
space is that provides a condensed
visualization of design process that
allows you to engage with the process
directly it was predicated on results
from interviews that we had with graphic
product and architectural designer so
let me just take you through what you
see on the y-axis we have a number of
channels it's called research
inspiration concepts prototype and
communication as an attempt to capture a
generalized design process if you don't
like that that's fine you can change it
and configure it in the tool every
filled circle is a representation of an
artifact it could be a concept sketch
could be an AutoCAD prototype it could
be example that you found on the web and
you can select them and look at the
thumbnails and open them up for editing
on the x-axis that is time and we
cluster the artifacts based upon
creation time we use creation time
because it gives us a stable
representation once I place it it stays
there's across implications of the tool
so just to put this in context what
you're looking at is the visualization
of process of an architectural designer
who is Martin who is think working to
remodel the dome of the observatory at
our institution and what you notice is
they start with some background research
in this case it was lighting conditions
they moved on to have a couple of bursts
of inspirational example flying in this
case that was domes from around the
world
the second burst was coincided with some
concept sketches that they drew followed
by some AutoCAD prototypes that they
created and there was continual
communication with the supervisor and
peers throughout and the point that I
want to make is that you can read and
tell stories about process with this
type of visualization that you cannot do
with a file centric approach one of our
challenges though is we really wanted to
make this as low cost as we possibly
could and so the way that we approached
this problem
is that we tried to map your
organizational strategy to our
visualization and we use things such as
your file names your file extensions
your folder hierarchies your folder
names as well as the creation times okay
and the rules are a bit more complex
than what we have here but the basic
idea was you could say something well if
your file is in there is a PDF or a
document that ends with Doc and it's in
user research background or so
combination then categorize it as
research in our tool ok and so the more
closely aligned the way that you
organize is with what we expect then the
lower the cost of creating the
visualization if you have no
organizational strategy whatsoever then
I would have to concede that I probably
can't help you if we map it and we get
it wrong you can move it around in the
tool and that would that would actually
stay persistent okay so one of the
things that you can do with the tool is
you can capture stories and the way that
you capture stories if you select the
icon in the upper right and you can put
it into the route to what we call the
reflection channel once you do that the
system prompts you to associate a number
of artifacts with that story ok and the
story can be anything that is memorable
to you as a designer it can be a proud
moment it can be a lesson learned it
could be a critical incident but what
we're trying to do is make it explicit
in the visualization so you can revisit
it later on so you get prompted you can
you can add and associate the artifacts
and you can put as many in there as you
want and actually one of my favorite
features of the tools you can come back
later on and export that into a
PowerPoint presentation to share some of
those lessons learned with colleagues
you can also mark your favorite
materials and so if you have an artifact
that you're particularly proud of you
think is inspirational you want to
revisit for any reason you can mark it
and we do it with a star so you can pick
as many as you want and it makes it pop
out of the visualization so you can
revisit it very quickly later on
and the final thing that I'll share with
you the tool actually does much more
than this but I'll share one other goal
that we had based upon the results of
interviews that we did is that they want
to look at the distribution of effort
and this was a very challenging problem
because we didn't want to have to
instrument every application that one
uses to record say editing time and so
the way that we approach the problem is
that we looked at the changes to the
modification date at the level of the
file system and so our assumption was
that every time you do a save it changes
the modification date and you're not
going to do a save unless you made a
meaningful change and so basically what
we do is we're counting the number of
times that you essentially save that
artifact we collect that data for
everything that's in the system we store
it and then we rank it per channel and
we display the ones that are at the top
10% chosen arbitrarily you can change it
if you want as an unfilled circle so
that you can make it easily identifiable
individualization so just to illustrate
why that might be interesting is here's
one that was there's a lot of effort
made to that pick their concept it was
very early in the process so that could
indicate premature commitment to a
concept and that might warrant a change
in process or at least a discussion as
to why that was the case so we did an
evaluation of this and we had seven
users all trained in either graphic or
architectural design and the way that
worked is that they gave us two projects
that they felt were similar in size and
scope we built our representation in our
system for them because we wanted to
test the utility of the visualization
first not get too caught up and whether
or not the mapping was perfect and then
we just recreated their own
representation in the lab they would
come in and we would engage them in a
bit of storytelling and so they would
just talk about the project by itself no
representation and then with one of the
two representations other project other
representation and we compared the
differences in terms of the measured
outcomes they would tell more and longer
stories when they used our tool in terms
of word count then with other
representation and they rated it better
for telling stories noticing patterns
estimating effort and just overall
preference so it's not definitive
because the you know the sample size was
small it was
single study but it's at least promising
other interesting things that we found
is that they wanted to marketer a
shion's decisions and key milestones in
that reflection channel so you can
imagine having a more kind of elaborate
visual vocabulary of things that you
could store there and another thing that
we found is that they would be more
careful with the naming if they knew
that the visualization was based upon
their strategy for how they organize
things then they might change that
because they knew that that would be
impacting that visualization that would
be created and the other things there's
a lot of enthusiasm they were really
interested in having a visualization
that allowed them to engage in explicit
acts of reflection and that made me
really excited is that got me to think a
lot about you know how you might use
this in the future
and so one of the things is everybody
asked me to put my data in the cloud so
what if I did that what if I put all
design artifacts in the cloud and what
I'm going to argue is that that could
make actually building that type of
visualization really easy and you could
share it which would be really
interesting to me to make it more social
and the reason I think it might make it
interesting is sudden you have access to
a very large corpus of organizational
strategies that you didn't have before
and so you could analyze that corpus of
data and you could try to build very
robust mappings and then construct that
type of visualization as a value add and
not just use it as a passive storage
archive so I think that could be really
interesting moving forward so reflection
space was built for an individual user
but we know that design is as much of a
social process as it is an individual
effort one of the things that makes
design a social process is that you
often have to get feedback on your ideas
and so let me just illustrate with an
example why this is such an important
component of design I can summarize this
as JCPenney had a really great idea for
a tea kettle unfortunately didn't work
out so well for them and it's somewhat
of an amusing example but the reality
was this was a national embarrassment
for JCPenney they had to take this tea
kettle off all the shelves they had to
issue
public apology they got a lot of
negative press and they wound up in my
talk and so I think this is a really
interesting example because it
highlights one of the key reasons why
you need feedback in design and that's
to compare intention to perception and
so you as a designer often always have
an intent what is it you're trying to
communicate and other people may or may
not get that perception it's not like
when you write a paper and you're trying
to say something and you think it's
unassailable you give it to your advisor
and it comes back with all red ink and
you're like how could you not possibly
get what I was trying to say and so it's
that difference between intent and
perception and I would argue that good
feedback is necessary but not always
easy and so there are a number of known
strategies for getting feedback I mean
you can organize a critique you can ask
peers you can submit to an online
community but they have both benefits
and limitations and so when you organize
a critique it's very heavyweight it's
unlikely you're gonna do that for
day-to-day decision making and if you're
not familiar with the with the kind of
design domain of training and design is
probably unlikely that you're even
familiar with that technique at all
you can informally ask peers but we know
through research that the feedback that
come backs is often overly positive you
might be reluctant to share in the first
place due to the fear of criticism and
my own work has shown that you might
have a fear of interrupting other
people's work you could submit it to an
online community but the research
results on this don't really paint a
very rosy picture and so the feedback
that you get often is very limited in
terms of the quantity and it's
relatively shallow so you get things
like wow nice job
way to go versus oh wow that's really
not very good and that's really not what
people want to engage with and try to
get the insights into improving their
design so I would have to think more
about how crowds might be engaged to
offer deeper more meaningful feedback
and I drew a lot of inspiration from
work that Steve and Ellen this Gerber
dead and what they had done is they used
crowds to do a/b testing
to collect preferences for which one you
like a versus B and then as a designer
you can get that signal and try to
figure out what decision that you want
to make and so I love this idea
but I want to try to push it a bit
further and think about how it could get
crowds to provide more deeper more
meaningful feedback the challenge is
that crowds don't really have any
expertise in design so if I show you an
idea and I say what do you think of it
what do I expect somebody to say who
doesn't have training in that discipline
okay so that was a challenge but if I
ask the question in a different way and
I said what's you know the first thing
that comes to mind when you see that
design what's the first thing that you
notice how is my communication goal
coming through to you then you can tell
me your reaction and that's something
that you can control and that insight
led to a system that we called voyant
which is to play on the word clairvoyant
helping you to see and this is a system
that leverages crowd workers a
non-expert crowd to provide feedback on
a visual design that feedback is
primarily perception oriented feedback
and the design of the system was
predicated on the results of interviews
that we did with people who had a wide
spectrum of design experience from nine
designers just doing design work all the
way to experts and we asked them if you
had a large audience of non experts what
would you want to ask them and from the
responses we're able to extract five
themes and we implemented those into the
tool and so you can get elements this is
literally what people can see in the
design what first notice so what people
actually see first and so establishing
part of the visual hierarchy impression
so what's the first word or phrase that
comes to mind when you look at the
design guidelines so we started with
what's known as the crab university
principles but contrast repetition
alignment and proximity and what you
would get with that is just a rating of
1 to 7 about how well people felt like
your design was adhering to each of
those principles and very similar with
the goals so goals are about your
communication goals again you get a
rating from 1 to 7 so the way that it
works is that you go to a publicly
accessible website
crowd feedback tap me if you have your
web computer open you can go there now
you upload your design image and here
what you have is poster design that was
done as a student design project and the
idea here was to try to engage customers
in a restaurant to try and your
smoothies stations that we put over the
top and try to help them engage with
that okay so we're gonna try the new
drink grab attention you can configure
your audience so you can configure it
based upon age location gender and try
to match that audience to the intended
audience that you have for the design
you can configure which other types of
feedback that you want and for some of
them you can add additional parameter so
if you configure the goals for instance
the system would prompt you to enter in
you know with as few words as possible
make it accessible to a layperson what
is your communication goal for the
design you can enter as many as you want
once you click Submit it will decompose
that task into a series of micro tasks
and put it onto Mechanical Turk and the
the workers are asked to do three things
very simple first give us your reaction
and so if it's the task about
Impressionist tell us the first word or
the phrase that comes to mind when you
look at that design if it's a goal or a
guideline it's give us a rating on a
scale of one to seven of how well you
think that design meets that rating or
it meets that guideline or goal and the
second thing is do an annotation so
point out the elements in the visual
design that relate to your action that
you had and the third thing which is
optional is you can offer an explanation
of why you gave the reaction and the
annotation that you're done and so we do
this for a large number of people and
then we aggregate and present the
results back to at the user and you get
a visualization that looks something
like this this is the one for
impressions and if you're the the user
this is what you see okay and so in this
case for impressions we do the
representation as a word cloud and so
all five types of feedback followed the
same pattern we give you an overview
representation we give you the markers
on the design that associate with each
of the pieces of feedback and then the
explanations
so here for example you can select the
different words in the word cloud and
see which elements of your design went
with that alternatively you can come
over to the design and look at the
markers and select a subset and see
which words were associated with those
markers so this is all about intention
versus perception and so the person who
created this design found a number of
interesting things from this so first of
all you know is color colorful retro
fresh is that really what you're trying
to communicate one of the interesting
things that came out of the word cloud
was the word sunny and it turns out this
was because of this element here she had
no idea that people gonna associate that
with the Sun it looks like the Sun to me
but it wasn't intentional on her part
another thing that was really
interesting that she learned from the
feedback was people were associating the
word strawberry apple and juice with the
colors in the poster and she didn't
really make that intentional and what
she discovered was that she could
literally make people to taste her
design by choosing the appropriate
colors and so with a very simple set of
feedback she was learning really
interesting things about what she was
communicating what she was not
communicating and how she might improve
that the other set another set of
feedback that you get is the ratings of
communication goals and here the goals
that were entered were trying a new
drink and grabbing attention
okay so again this is supposed to be a
above like a smoothie station in a
restaurant and try to get people come
over and try it with this part you get a
data visualization that is an
interactive bar chart okay and assesses
how well you're meeting your goals so in
this case they did relatively well and
both but trying a new drink didn't rate
as high as grabbing attention and so you
can maybe sharpen that particular goal
on the next iteration the other thing
that bar chart is interactive and so you
can select different bars or subsets and
you can do this to look at some
interesting patterns that we've noticed
and so for example we've had a bimodal
distribution where certain people really
liked something and others don't you
compare and contrast that feedback now
there are additional types of feedback
you get elements and first notice in
guidelines and it's very similar in
terms of the data representation and the
interactions that you have and I would
just refer you to the paper we have
forthcoming on this and let me just talk
a bit about the evaluation what I was
really interested in the valuation is
can you actually learn anything about
this feedback about your design okay so
we collected eight in progress designs
and it ran kind of the gamut we had
magazine covers we had 3d renderings we
had graphic logos we have webpage
designs and we worked with each of those
people who created the designs to
understand their goals
we took their goals we took their
designs we uploaded into our system and
once we had the feedback we asked them
to come back and we talked about what
they could learn as they walk through
that feedback on their own idea so I
just want to share with you one anecdote
that kind of exemplifies what we found
and so in this case this was a 3d
rendering that the person who created it
wanted to communicate two things they
want to communicate chinese-style and
they wanted to communicate that was a
teapot okay and what they found from the
feedback both from the impressions which
are not shown and from the the goals
which are shown is that it didn't really
communicate chinese-style very well and
it didn't really communicate a teapot
people actually perceived it as a coffee
pot and so based upon digging into the
the data and digging into the
explanations they decided they would
make two changes one is they would add
tea cups to try to convey better that
it's a tea kettle and not a coffee pot
and the second was to put maybe like a
dragon pattern to better communicate
Chinese style okay so the point is that
everybody learned something about their
design and in many cases it wasn't just
one set of feedback it was the
collection of things where they get
synthesize you know interesting ideas
okay well we also tracked how much to
cost and how long it took in terms of
cost it was about ten dollars and that
was perceived as a fair trade-off
because they didn't have to organize a
critique or repeatedly interrupt peers
we did absolutely no optimization and so
it's really interesting think about
that is an upper bound you know how good
could we do if we start to optimize cost
to optimize quality and to optimize time
the second thing is we really emphasize
finding problems and I'm okay with that
because if finding problems is a
significant outcome with the work how do
you iterate if you don't know what
you're trying to address they're very
hard to do but it is interesting to
think about how you might engage the
crowd to help brainstorm solutions so
let me just kind of look forward with
this project a little bit what if I
could make the feedback both fast and
affordable and so I could go through and
optimize the cost by doing a better job
of structuring my workflows and I can
use Michaels techniques such as the
retainer model to make it also ready
fast and by fast I mean what if I could
give this to you like three to four
times a day what would be the impact on
design process if I could do that I mean
I don't know but I think it would be
really really interesting to think about
how that's going to be integrated into
the creative workflow and another thing
looking forward what if I was to
aggregate and collect all of the data
that you've got across all iterations
and all projects that you've ever done
and I know a little bit about the data I
know that you have word clouds I know
they have bar charts is connected to the
design
I got explanations I got the markers
right what if I collected that over a
long period of time and I created a
visualization of that
what could you as a designer what could
you learn from that what else could you
do with that I think that's a really
interesting thing covers a short one
okay sort of interesting is that both of
the criteria the it it's a tea pot and
then it's Chinese style seem like
depends who you're asking
it's like who the crowd is sure at least
if you're someone who's in computer
graphics at all you're gonna go of
course that's a teapot well I'm gonna
guess that was a computer graphics
student that might have been one of
their projects right so yeah but you
know this is subjective but it's okay
I mean that was meaningful to the person
who created the design
in the sense of who the people are who
are doing the assessment as who your
audience is and how that okay I wanted
to look chinese-style but - who -
someone yeah so English I know well sure
and so what are the really cool things
about this we haven't done it yet but I
would love to try to separate out the
audience and so right now all the
audience comes back as being the same
and so there's many different ways that
one wants to slice that audience and so
it could be then just separate based
upon culture the age the gender but one
of the really interesting is how do I
separate on expertise the one of the
challenges here I think is that crowd
work often devalues expertise some
people are much better at this type of
task than others so how would I
differentially weigh what people are
really good at that type of tasks are
swish with the goals and the guidelines
versus those who are not because right
now we weigh them the same I just don't
think that's fair yeah okay but good
question okay so the feedback from
voyant helps the individual make
decisions on a design but you know
decisions are often made in a group
setting not necessarily by the
individual in online communities for
example the design discussions or this
the community that often engages in
design thinking in the discussions and I
was really interested in how that
transpires you have people who have
never met and probably never will
they're using a fairly impoverished
interface which is the web forum to
engage in ideation about interesting
design problems so how does that work
how does it unfold I really wanted to
probe deeper about that one of the
things that we had to do is was pick a
community that we wanted to study and we
selected Drupal it's a very well-known
very successful open source content
management system it has about 500,000
websites that have been created with
Drupal it has roughly an equal number of
people that have registered to
contribute to that project the design
discussions that relate to the user
interface happen in this issue q so if
you have a feature request or a
usability problem that you want to
report you put it into the issue queue
and other community members can come and
join and talk about the issue offer up
concrete proposals for how to solve it
engage in deliberation and then
eventually if things go well you can
pick one and push it into the product
and so we also needed to think about how
we wanted to study those particular
discussions and we chose the lens of
what's called consensus building
consensus building is a distinct form of
decision making where you value the
social process of the discussion as much
as the final outcome and the consensus
is often determined to be reached when
you have a decision and everybody can
live with it we thought that was an
interesting lens to look at because the
design discussions often exhibit
conflict due to people advocating
strongly for their ideas and is
therefore really important for those
discussions to unfold in a way that is
respectful and well respectful and
courteous because the community depends
upon people coming back and continuing
to communicate and contribute to that
community and so we first just wanted to
quantify how many of those discussions
actually reach consensus okay so we
analyzed a fairly large corpus of the
data a number of design discussions
messages patches and contributors we had
a very surprising finding about 42% of
the UI design discussions do not reach
consensus so very significant finding
because other all the potential
consequences so all the missed
opportunities to improve the product all
the effort that gets wasted into
building the ideas then deliberation and
it doesn't go anywhere and one of the
problems is that that could cause people
to leave the community and not come back
and it's actually not just Drupal
wikipedia has the same problem so this
is an article from a recent Wall Street
Journal article where they argue that
there's a mass exodus of people from
Wikipedia and one of the problems is
that people get very frustrated with the
decision making that happen
so they make a change and it gets
reverted they don't understand why so if
you're frustrated with it you can just
leave and not come back and it's very
easy to leave and that's happening and
so one of the really interesting things
about this though when I looked at that
graph is that maybe the right metric for
consensus building is not whether or not
you reach an agreeable solution it's
whether you reduce the outflow of people
from the community that's a very
different way of thinking about
consensus building in communities done
we have today now there are many reasons
why one why the discussions may not
reach consensus but we think part of the
reason is that the web forums that
people use have no mechanism for
consensus building at all so we wanted
to explore you know what would it mean
from a technical side in terms of the
interface to actually build in features
that support consensus this is a really
challenging problem and said we're
guided by two high-level principles one
is that we wanted to embed feasible and
sound strategies into the interface and
our approach was to first enumerate many
different strategies that we could
locate in the literature both from the
Siri and the practice of consensus and
then we wanted to select a subset of
those that we felt were feasible and
that would have utility for our tool yet
you have to be realistic
I mean we're creating a tool we're not
creating a human moderator and so maybe
as the first step what we thought is
let's try to give people a better
discussion experience and maybe you know
in the future we can try to lead and
convert those discussions to a consensus
but maybe that wouldn't be a goal we
could reach in the near term and we want
to integrate into the existing community
and this also is a really difficult
challenge but all the work in Drupal it
happens in that issue Cuse where the
designers are it's where the developers
are it's where all the work gets done
and so we wanted to have an impact on
the community and learn and discover
principles of consensus through
authentic use as opposed to just
creating a one-off interface that people
would you say in the loud
okay so based on those goals we develop
a system called proceed it's a script it
runs inside the client browser and what
it does it basically rewrites the HTML
with the Drupal server but we also use
our own server to track certain state
information that we need to render the
interface the way that we do and so what
you're looking at here and the first
thing when to point out is on kind of
the right side this is the actual
discussion in the Drupal community we do
not modify it at all
the interface works with any discussion
in that community that you want to go
look at and participate in what we do is
we basically wrapper on the top and
along the left and so we have three
different pages that we offer the home
page is what you see here what we call
an idea page with a show and an
invitation page with the show one of the
basic elements of consensus is you have
to know what's going on in discussion so
on the Left panel we give you a number
of live lenses to help you do that we
help you filter comments based upon the
experience of the person who submitted
the comment a community endorsement so
what other people say is an interesting
discussion point conversational behavior
so kind of a rapid back-and-forth
between two people and the content in
terms of which messages have ideas and
which have patches and so the benefit is
that you can use those lenses to help
track and revisit key points of the
discussion a second strategy is
including users who can help contribute
to moving that discussion forward and
the way that we do this is through the
invite page and we generate a list of
all the community members and we show
how they score on different criteria
that we know to be important for
consensus in the domain so we talked
about how much experience they've had in
the community the number of patches that
they contributed how many threads that
they participated in that have been
closed or as a proxy for consensus and
then remember interactions they've had
with people in the current ongoing
discussion and so you can use this to
help fill perceived gaps and so if
you're in a discussion and you're like
and you wish that you had more
experienced participants you can come to
this page and look at those who have
more experience than what you guys have
currently and you can find those who
have bridges to people who are already
engaged in the discussion because one is
that will create an opportunity to maybe
to bring them in and second we know that
it's looked easier to reach consensus
with people that we know than people
that we don't I want to talk about the
idea centric page but first I want to
tell you about how do we know about
ideas and so we have a very clever
strategy we ask and so what we do is we
rewrite the HTML on the page for
authoring a comment and we inject a very
small amount of input that we request
when you're authoring that comment we
simply ask this is Comet proposed a
concrete idea if not does it refer to an
idea and if so which comment number does
it go with and then tell us your
disposition do you strongly object up to
strongly support the idea that you're
referring to now this has been a very
long thread of research and csw work
where basically what we say is that if
you just give us a little bit of input
we can render the discussion better for
you the problem however is that it's
easy to fall into the trap to over
engineer the system think design
rationale systems for instance where
without any kind of bound on what you're
asking for the structured input you just
go too far it becomes too cumbersome to
use and so we think this is interesting
because the community puts a constraint
on us to think very carefully about how
much input we're actually going to ask
for for fear of a backlash from the
community members themselves ok so this
is all of the input that we request
initially for the ideas and then we can
do some interesting things with it as a
short okay you must install our
extension to get this if you don't
install our extension you just see it
the way that you always would see it
okay so assuming that the users will
give us that small amount of input then
we can render what we call an idea
centric page and this is trying to
organize the ideas or organize the
discussion around the ideas and again
that's one of the kind of one of the
tenets of doing consensus building it's
ready to focus on the idea proposals so
on the left
is you get the concrete proposals that
were attached to what people said were
an idea you get the status you get a set
of user-defined criteria which I'll come
back to and you get a set of comments
that are organized in different channels
and so the top one is supportive
comments the middle one is neutral
comments and the bottom one are what we
call a constructive comment which is a
polite way of saying it's a critical
comment and so what you can see is that
you can look for ideas that need further
attention you can look for conflict you
can look for things that already have
good support and things that have the
lack of support we do one other thing if
you give me an extreme position either I
really don't like this so I object to it
strongly or I strongly support it we
render it as a slightly larger circle to
call attention to it by the other
community members and give you a sense
that you have a stronger voice in the
discussion okay you can establish
criteria and the way you do the criteria
is you select the icon here next to the
criteria column and then it prompts you
with a dialog and you can either modify
what's there or you can add an
additional set so if you add another
piece of criteria it gets replicated for
every idea in that same column and what
you end up with is criteria that's user
defined it's visually persistent and
it's interactive and so if you wanted to
rate how an idea it here's one of the
criteria you can do that with a slider
and anybody in the community can do this
the system prompts you to enter a
comment with it to create accountability
so it's unlikely gonna make a
modification unless you feel strongly
about that change should happen the last
one that I'm going to talk about that we
actually do more than this is promoting
a constructive tone and so our tool
realizes this strategy in two ways first
when a comment is authored the system
highlights all of the negative words
okay we don't make any sittin we know
any interpretation we're not trying to
censor people we simply highlight what
those words are according to linguistic
inquiry
orell IWC and we simply remind you why
it's a good thing to have a constructive
tone and you can just choose to go
forward and post it as is or you might
go back and revise it okay it's up to
you and the second way is to promote a
constructive tone is that we have a
constraint in the system so it's that
when you have a new idea
the first comment has to be supportive
and so we try to extract the good of an
idea before people can start making
critical comments on it and this is
should be familiar to everybody if
you're in a face-to-face discussion and
you submit an idea and it immediately
gets attacked how does that make you
feel
you probably disengage and hear the
problem with disengagement is you leave
the community and you don't come back
remember that Wikipedia graph that's the
problem okay so it's an early prototype
we know that we have a lot more work to
do but we had it to the point where we
could actually get some feedback from
the community members themselves and so
the way that we did this is we did it as
a walkthrough we found some active
discussions that had some tension in
them where people were advocated
strongly for their ideas and we
downloaded those discussions and we we
mirrored the mono server and we
constructed and rendered that discussion
in our tool we invited people who were
participating in those discussions to
come participate in our study and for
those who responded in the affirmative
we gave them our script ask them to the
install we gave them a link to their own
discussion so they could see it and we
gave them a set of tasks to experience
the different key features of the system
and so you know overall we got very
favorable reactions from the community
members which I was really excited about
and their favorite aspects were the idea
centric and views and the criteria lists
were the things I liked the most and in
terms of their subjective responses they
rated our tool as being more effective
for consensus building then the current
web forum that they use and I know
that's not definitive but it's at least
promising another couple of interesting
things that we found is that they desire
minimal change they have such a way of
working now that they're just really
attached to it they're very resistant to
change and so the idea is that you can
inject this type of tool with a very
small
Delta over what they do now and then try
to grow it over time the second thing
that we found is they really wanted
buying in that community is all about
buying and contributing right so the
recommendation that they had to us was
to open a discussion about the tool
about consensus building in general and
invite the community to come talk about
it and that's exactly what we've done
and we're just now we're trying to look
at where that discussion is heading and
starting to collect some data and
looking forward I mean one of the things
I think is really intellectually
challenging is how do you measure the
impact of a tool like this in a
community and when I first approached
the problem I was thinking wow we should
really just be looking at the number of
discussions that now reach consensus
that didn't before but when I started
looking at the data and looking at you
know the graphs of say Wikipedia it
started to think about well maybe that's
not the right metric after all maybe
what we should really be looking at is
whether we reduce the outflows of
volunteers from this type of community
and maybe there's other metrics that we
can use - okay so let me offer a couple
of pathways forward for future work and
then I will conclude
so the first pathway I want to talk
about is I want to make an argument that
ideas used to be difficult to get and
that really spawned 40 years of research
into how we do better idea generation
but now I would argue that the world has
changed and ideas are now cheap and one
of the reasons that we're cheap is
because we can engage crowds so for
example this is from Starbucks my
Starbucks ideas calm website and what
they do is they engage the crowd to give
them ideas for how they might improve
products or consumer experiences and
people do engage with that it generates
about a thousand ideas a month if not
more
and so what I'm arguing is that the
problem is no longer that we don't have
enough ideas we have too many and so
future design tools especially those
that try to engage with a crowd need to
think more about ideas selection and not
just idea generation and maybe that's
just a step
it's down to something even bigger we
all really think about how crowds change
the creative workflow throughout and I
think that's something very interested
in thinking about in the future we also
want to think about how do we help
people select the best or the most
innovative idea and overcome the
psychological bias of always choosing
the safest or the most familiar idea
which we know happens a lot and the
second pathway I want to talk about just
briefly is the motivation of creative
effort so I'm a really big fan of
Theresa a Mobius work who argues that
intrinsic motivation is one of the three
one of three key ingredients for
creative work look I can give you
examples I can give you feedback I can
give you spatial maps but unless you're
motivated to translate that into
creative outcomes it's probably not
going to happen and so how do you build
technology that motivates creative
effort that's really interesting and so
as an analogy I was thinking about Nikes
social media application and I keep plus
run and it's one of my favorite ones and
what you can do with this before you go
on a run is you can invoke the
application and put a link on to your
Facebook page and people can cheer you
on and I suppose in the headphones it's
like go go go go right having been a
runner in my earlier ears I would find
that really motivating what is the
equivalent for design thinking on that
rhetorical note sorry for the
cliffhanger I'm going to conclude and
I've made a number of contributions to
design thinking tools for individuals
for groups and for communities I talked
about the work we've done on spatial
maps we developed visualizations to help
extract meaning for prior activity we
showed how to use non expert crowds to
generate feedback on preliminary designs
and we talked about some results and a
tool that supports consensus building
and online communities and so thanks for
attention I can take questions now
Michael so I've been questioned about
the play on
I wonder if this approach could be
extended to not just sort of a
subjective or perceptual feedback but
also to cute maybe a more grounded sense
of how well I'm doing you can imagine
for example anchoring the system with a
number of designs that have sort of
known quality bars and then through the
process of sort of comparison show me
sort of quantitatively your design is
sort of sitting here on this scale so
now I'm either in ooh I I want if I like
this bar I need to work harder or I'm
actually achieving like I wonder if
there are ways to give people more
direct or quantitative feedback about
how they're doing well I mean yeah I
think there absolutely is and so one of
the ways I just do it through iteration
and you know just like you an
interaction design is you do the first
one to credit kata baseline and then you
do the the subsequent iterations to
compare to what your original one was
and see if you're going in the right
direction I think you can do the same
thing here and so on multiple iterations
or even you wanted an exploration at
certain points you can compare and
contrast if you're improving so one of
the things that I really want to do is
I'm really sensitive to engineering
trust into the system and if you make
what you think to be really good
improvements on your design and it comes
back as having worse feedback you're
gonna call into question whether or not
that's meaningful or not so what I
really want to do is try to help people
elaborate what the changes are look and
see if the crowd gives you an improved
response and then compare that to the
changes that you said that you made and
hopefully give people confidence that
the system is actually recognizing when
you make improvements well we're doing
that right now
and so we really want to check the
consistency because my concern is that
if appears to be a random process I mean
what is the perception from the purpose
of the user they're not really going to
have a lot of confidence in the system
so I want to give them confidence that
that would give them consistent feedback
if they actually make improvement
that the crowd recognizes that those
improvements were made if you watch the
thing at me I think we get some very
consistent response about the first
things people notice well there are if
you there are a lot of number of
different kind of applications that kind
of they do roughly similar things but
when I look at them they all do it and
different why and well that tells me
that we don't really know how to do this
very well I got and so hopefully we can
kind of discover some principles and
communicate that and they get engendered
in some of these other other tools yeah
so for one that lis part where you uh
like identified like negative words and
then and then like just highlight them
um you look at like like what actually
before and after it was like so I
suppose some thing wanted to post
something goes like this is a terrible
idea
like what did they actually change it -
okay so person that was the proceeding
system but but I get yeah so he's asking
about whether or not when I highlight
the word so people actually make changes
what kind of change do they make they're
just like we replaced terrible with the
word that you won't highlight or they
actually changed into a constructive I
wish I had a data point on that I do not
have a data point on that yacht but
hopefully I can come back and give you a
data point where people make changes I
actually think that they will um and but
I don't know how suggested that we need
to be right now I'm very kind of I don't
want to make interpretations for them I
want them to come to their own
conclusion that they need to make an
adjustment but I I think I think they
will I really do I'm very optimistic
about that because when you see it and
it's in front of you and you look at all
this forward self highlighted the house
just kind of a visceral kind of impact
on you it's like wow I'm really not
being very positive and so you might go
back and choose and there's you know we
know that you know from reviews and
doing reviews we know that there's ways
to say things that exactly the same way
but it's more constructive and that's
what I really want people to do I mean
you have to change what you say just
make it more constructive in the way
that you communicate it to the other
person and it's really
important because that social process is
such a key element it's so easy to leave
that community that if you get
frustrated and you're upset about
somebody says you can just leave and not
come back end it but yet it depends on
people you know their willingness to
volunteer so I think designs where they
like put these are the puzzle the pros
of this idea these are the consoles but
it's across the screen and then they're
the the normal forums they just come and
one after the other and this one is it's
easy to see the pros and cons on one the
other one it's easier to follow the
discussion I was wondering I kind of
it's well there's there's many different
solution possibilities that one has here
right and so you know we had one that we
thought was effective but we'd be open
to change in it but we map your
disposition in other words if you like
it or not we map it to space right so
the top channel gives you what people
you know the people who like it and the
bottom channel gives to those who do not
want to be constructive so we just map
it on the space to be direct about your
question right there so the top row are
supportive the bottom row here are those
that are constructive okay and that gets
repeated for each of that eeeh so it's
mapped on the space there's three
channels okay and so we try to be
consistent for each idea and what you
want to do is compare and contrast this
so you can look for things that if you
don't have anything in the bottom row
that means that people are very
supportive of their slot on the top if
there's an equal number top and bottom
and there's a lot of them that means
there's tension and conflict if there's
only things on the bottom and nothing on
the top row that means that well maybe
that's not really gonna go anywhere and
then the ones that are rendered like a
little bit large like wow I really like
either really do like this or I really
don't and it calls attention to it
that's what we're trying to do it's so
easy to miss comments and that in the
discussion and you feel as if I said
something always listening to me here we
call it out so if you're really don't so
port it or you really do it's a parent
goes to the discussion I just want to
mention a possible suggestion with the
analysis but where you're highlighting
the negative words yes yes this is very
implicit so suggestions would be welcome
oh I mean it seems like since you have
the forum it'd be great to simply look
at before and after the introduction of
this show sure what you're the
statistical change in language being
used which is maybe not the desired
effects yeah and it comes back yeah I
love the idea yeah and it comes back to
that question how do you measure the
impact of a tool like this in the
community and just measure the number of
things that reach consensus may not be
the right approach and so what you're
talking about is a change in the way
that people converse about ideas that's
a really big change and so if we could
show that here I think that would be
fantastic
it's just how long does that change how
long does it take it's probably not
going to be immediate and so we have to
follow this for a long period of time so
that that's the overview over transition
all the posts or discussion people
haven't been thinking about like with
seeing the conversation obvious in the
forms maybe like just pull out the
native sense or positive sentence but
they're just with when they're posted or
marking it blue or red but you cannot
visually guess through the discussion so
got a better sense base in the contact
completely followed what what you said
about this but we're certainly open to
and many different things in the way
that the discussion is visualized we
don't necessarily think this is you know
the final right solution it's more of
just ever a prototype and a way a lot to
allow us to probe what people really
want in that community and then be
responsive to that and try to iterate on
the design
so if certainly all the things come up
like that we'd be happy to incorporate
it
what how would you say bran is different
from traditional a/b testing is it
because you get more structure back well
it's different than a/b testing I think
what we're what we're doing is we're
making the feedback really cheap and so
now what you can do is you can engage
crowds through your local workspace so
literally with you know a pulldown say
in Photoshop you can engage that crowd
and now it's probably cost too much it
takes too long but you know what if we
can do this and a couple of hours and
get you feedback three to four times a
day that's where we really want to go
and so we're making the feedback really
inexpensive to get and so now when you
try out different things you can
immediately test it and then use that to
have very tight iterations I think
that's really exciting one more question
something comes to mind that I could
quickly just add a positive or negative
so what we wanted to not just think
about a visualization is output but
think about the visualization as input
and so we can offer some constraints
through this way so this is where we
have this constraint that if you have a
newly submitted idea that has no
comments yet then the first one needs to
be in the top row that way people see
the good of the idea and can really
learn about the idea before they start
making constructive comments and the
part is again about the social process
you know making people feel better about
the discussion and you if my idea
doesn't get picked well at least people
said something that was positive about
it right
you